we continue our work on a Jungian
approach to dream interpretation today's
episode involves the types of
compensatory dreams we may have and an
examination of the difference between an
objective and a subjective interpretive
approach to a dream let's start by
turning our attention to something that
we've touched on before and that is the
process of compensation recall I said
that most dreams are of a compensatory
type compensation of course is the
natural balancing function of the psyche
so the dream compensates for the ego
stance but what does this look like and
what types of compensation are possible
in the psyche in the form of dreams
well Jung argued that there are three
compensatory positions possible in
dreams these are first the conscious
attitude is one-sided so the dream
provides the opposite position second
the conscious attitude is correct so the
dream affirms this position and third
the conscious attitude is in the middle
so the dream coincides with this I'm
going to create some many dreams to try
and give you examples of how these three
positions can arise in dreams all these
examples of course are quite fictitious
what would the first form of
compensation being the dream provides
the opposite position to your one-sided
ego stance look like in a dream let's
say that you had a very one-sided
conscious attitude towards your work
viewing your work as the whole reason to
get up in the morning as providing for
all your needs as the central aspect of
your life you clearly have a one-sided
approach to your external world
and that is that all that involves is
work one night you had a dream in which
you went to work but no one recognized
you and your desk had disappeared and in
fact you no longer had any idea what you
actually did at work suddenly you find
yourself outside sitting by a lake with
your husband talking about how well the
kids are doing as they grow up you feel
calm as you chat with your husband
finally you walk to your car and your
husband says to you I like talking with
you like this I wish we could spend more
days each week by the lake just hanging
out and that's the end of the dream the
dream alerts you to the problem which is
overworked and radically reverses your
reliance on work to fulfill all your
needs the solution to the dream is one
in which you are given a possible
conscious attitude of how to be instead
of living as a workaholic let's look at
the form of compensation where your
dream confirms that you're holding on to
a conscious attitude that works for the
psyche let's take the same dreamer
we just used before and imagine that she
is well aware that she has to balance
out her life and her work and her family
life her dream is as follows I was at
work speaking to my manager my manager
was asking me how to make the perfect
loaf of bread I said that so long as you
had four cups of white flour to every
cup of whole wheat flour the bread will
rise perfectly and your family will love
it
that's the dream the dreamer may have
been aware of her work and home
relationships and chosen to work a
four-day week taking the fifth day off
to be with her family
in other words four days of work with
the fifth day at home just as in her
dream this balance was perfect
and a family enjoyed the dream of being
at home on Fridays so the dream affirms
the mix between work and home life or
for parts of white flour - one part of
whole wheat flour the third type of
compensatory treat dream is one in which
I'm sure you can work out an example for
yourself by now a final word about
compensatory dreams from Carl Jung in
the following quote he how it lines the
difference between compensatory and
prospect of dreams and the quote starts
I should like to distinguish between the
prospect of function of dreams and their
compensatory function the latter means
that the unconscious considered as
relative consciousness adds to the
conscious situation all those elements
from the previous day which remained
subliminal because of repression or
because they were simply too feeble to
reach consciousness this compensation in
the sense of being a self regulation of
the psychic organism must be called
purposive the prospect of function on
the other hand is an anticipation in the
unconscious of future conscious
achievements something like a
preliminaries exercise or sketch or a
plan roughed out in advance the
occurrence of prospective dreams cannot
be denied it would be wrong to call them
prophetic because at bottom they are no
more prophetic than a medical diagnosis
or a weather forecast they are merely an
anticipatory combination of
probabilities which may coincide with
the actual behavior of
things but need not necessarily agree in
every detail end quote
and that's from Young's collected works
volume eight paragraphs four nine two
and four nine three Jung then warns
about the misuse of prospect of dreams
by saying the following and I quote
although the prospect of function is in
my view an essential characteristic of
dreams one would do well not to
overestimate this function one might
easily be led to suppose that the dream
is a kind of psychopomp
which because of its superior knowledge
infallibly guides life in the right
direction end quote and that's from
collected works volume 8 paragraph four
nine four of crucial importance to our
understanding of how we go about
interpreting a dream is the issue of
whether we should work from an object of
interpretive stance or a subject of
interpretive stance in short the
difference between the approaches speaks
to how we react to the dream in an
object of approach the dream is viewed
as making a direct commentary on an
external world issue such as how you
deal with a colleague at work or how you
treat your kids the subject of stance on
the other hand relies on the idea that
all the parts of the dream are parts of
yourself in an object of interpretation
the dream is a direct comment on a
real-world experience in other words the
dream comments on an inter psychic issue
inter psychic means between you and
another or others whereas the word
intrapsychic refers to within you for an
object of approach a key idea is that if
the laws of physics hold in the dream
and that known people places or events
are the components of the dream you may
well consider taking an objective stance
to the dream interpretation so you
wouldn't walk through walls you wouldn't
see dragons a dead relative wouldn't
appear your parents if they're still
alive or the age they are today and they
look like they do today and they act
like they do today taken from this
standpoint the dream is more of a direct
report on the way you are handling
issues external to you one should always
examine the dream text for the
possibility of an objective interpretive
approach first if this does not appear
possible then and only then can you move
to a subjective approach as I mentioned
above in a subject of interpretation all
aspects of the dream are aspects of the
dreamers personality which means that
you in the dream or a dream ego a female
figure in the dream if you are male
often represents your anima and if you
are a female dreamer your shadow a male
figure in the dream may represent the
animus in a female dreamer and the
shadow in a male dreamer taken from a
subject of interpretive stance the dream
is a comment on the relationships within
one's psyche in other words yours it is
an intrapsychic comment there is a third
interpretive stance that I will just
mention and that is that the dream
represents a comment on the transference
in the analytic encounter I'll cover
this in a later episode on analysis